i talked to you right before the album
came out congrats on the success oh
thank you so much how did that feel it's
so exciting just like having i mean i
just i love what i do it's just grateful
to be here and still rocking and yes you
look amazing tonight who are we thank
you um this is ashton michael and it's
custom made for me we just went kind of
rock and roll like basically inspired by
like leather jacket turned into a dress
and then i'm wearing a lot of plaid
these days i love it and then check this
spiked bracelet
get that okay and it even comes off you
ready oh my god oh wait the bracelet
stays
we're setting a trend right now and then
we go
and that's how it's done
and that is how it's done avril lavigne
yes um you look it's so many big moments
lately
including you receiving flowers from
your forever fan taylor swift how did
that feel
i mean so sweet she's lovely i mean it
met her everything complicated up on
stage on her tour and then when my album
came out she like sent flowers and just
a sweet note saying that she was like
loving the new album
now the fans want to collab could that
happen i mean taylor's amazing i didn't
think would happen i'm down yeah
um so tonight uh big night anybody here
uh well you know first do you have a
date who's your date tonight um yes my
boyfriend mod son is here with me
amazing yeah i know you guys collaborate
together does it feel good to just have
a support on a night like tonight yeah i
mean we made the album together like we
co-wrote the songs and he he'll produce
and uh and like he's coming out on tour
with me and like we do we're like super
creative together so it's really fun and
yeah he's here we're hanging we're
hanging with like black bears here like
all our friends and music are here um
joining machine gun kelly on tour right
what's it gonna be like for you to tour
together
um so we just announced the american
tour and i'm going on tour with machine
gun kelly and it's gonna be so much fun
and in may i'm touring canada and i've
got other tour dates i'm announcing but
it's just so great to be back up on
stage especially with the new album love
sucks like the songs are so meant to be
performed live and just i can't wait to
get back out there on stage and
hang with all my friends on tour and
play all these festivals we have coming
up
i know when i talked to you about tour
you were like look i drink my i drink my
green juice i get my sleep but how do
you let loose how do you party or like
celebrate after a night like tonight at
iheart
tonight
like i think i'm gonna we're gonna go
out to dinner with like a bunch of our
friends
our musician friends and like labels and
managers and celebrate yeah so business
and pleasure okay yeah yeah um i just
had sean white here and he's like look
i'm totally open to acting and i said
well you know avril's making the skater
boy movie and he's like avril please
cass cool
did you you're like an agent thank you
i mean tony was going to be in it so i'm
like let's get up 100 i mean that would
be amazing
of course you can skateboard too if you
can snowboard uh
oh my god i like this thank you good i'm
so glad
um okay well anybody you're uh really
excited to see tonight old friends
you're excited to run into we got j-lo
in the house are you a jlo yeah i was
gonna say j-lo yeah for sure i love j-lo
but love me some j.lo she's getting the
icon award what do you think makes her
an icon i mean she's been doing this
forever she's first of all she's an
amazing actress and i love all of her
films and she's like gorgeous and she's
like an insane dancer and
she does it all amazing yeah she works
so hard like i really i have so much
respect for her like she's just been
killing it so
i love jlo i feel like you work so hard
i do
you have to
[Music]
you